Dr Zak Nik before I begin the question
and answers a little about myself in
1996 I accepted Islam at the University
of California
Berkeley and the lecture which
facilitated my acceptance of Islam was a
fraction of this lecture had I heard
this I probably would have been
overblown and
uh mashallah you some people are just
given that gift and uh you have been
given that gift I shouldn't praise
people in their presence
but now back to the question and
answers in order to make this run as
smoothly and quickly as possible I would
ask everyone in attendance tonight to
please keep your questions strictly to
the
topic to ask your question briefly
to be orderly at the mics and Q in a
line and do not
bunch and I would also like to remind
everyone here in the audience that we
are brothers and sisters in
humanity and for those non-muslims who
are with us
tonight you are our brothers and you are
our sisters and we will give you a
priority at the mics so if you have a
question we ask that the volunteers
facilitate those people in getting to
the mic
microphones and they have the priority
brothers and sisters if you came with a
non-muslim guest and they are slightly
shy please do motivate them to ask their
question because we have people who can
give the best answers
inshallah and uh for those Muslims here
you have many opportunities so please do
let the non-muslims ask their
questions uh we have three microphones
one in the rear for the brothers in the
front for the brothers and one in the
sister section here so if you have a
question try to make your way to these
one two three microphones written
questions will receive second priority
those questions at the microphone will
be answered first I know that we have
one very patient brother who is a
non-muslim and he waited this entire
talk to ask his question so at this time
I will go to the front mic in the Maes
section and ask the brother to please
state your
name your occupation and then briefly
State your question uh good evening
everyone um my name is adiya and I'm
doing my final year Engineering in
Chennai um though I'm a Hindu I have
been having this uh question about Islam
that I wanted to ask and no better a
person than Dr zakar nyak uh as you said
in your speak many many times the Holy
Quran was written 14400 years ago and is
considered the most worthy and the
latest Revelation given by Allah so I
have two questions to you Allah who
knows all why didn't he give his best of
Revelation the first time itself to the
first of Messengers and why did God take
so many times to give his best of
knowledge and my second question which
is related to this is even before the
Holy Quran was written that is 14400
years ago human beings had lived in the
Earth for thousands of years so why did
Allah the most merciful didn't give them
that best knowledge which he has given
us for the last 1400 Years thank you the
brother asked a very good question very
relevant question two questions both the
questions overlapping the answers he
said that why did Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
give this last and final Revelation
1,400 years ago why not in day one when
you means are there and second part is
the part of the same question that what
about the people who lived before 14
years ago they were deprived of the
Quran so if Allah is most merciful most
gracious most beneficient so isn't it
that the people earlier before 49 de
very good question to reply a question
my son he tells
me that ABA father you want me to become
a doctor why do you put me Nursery first
stander second standard then school then
College why don't you put me into
Medical College
directly if I want my son to become a
medical
doctor I don't have to put him into the
Medical College directly I have to First
Make The Ground very clear first he goes
into the pre- primary school then goes
into the school first standard onwards
on passes school then goes to the high
school then college and when he's fit
then he enters the Medical College
similarly almighty God who has knowledge
of the Unseen and knowledge of
everything he even knowledge of the
human beings so it is mentioned in the
Quran inah chapter number 13 verse
number 38 Allah
says that we have sent a revelation in
every age in every period by name four
are mentioned in the Quran T Zab in and
the Quran but there were several
Revelations sent the first revelation
almighty God knew that the human beings
had to develop if he would have revealed
the Quran at the first time at the time
of Adam peace be upon him he knew the
human beings won't be able to grasp it
that's the reason in the Revelation that
came before the Quran that's the injil
today we have the Bible though we don't
consider the Bible to be the inil but
some parts of the Bible may be the word
of God it's mentioned in the Bible in
the Gospel of John chapter number 16
verse number 12-4 Jesus Christ peace be
upon Him says I have many things to say
unto you but he cannot bear them now for
he when the spirit of truth shall come
he shall guide you onto all Tru he shall
show you the way to come he shall
glorify me so here Jesus Christ peace be
upon him he knew but yet he said that
you will not be able to grasp it
therefore when the last and final
Messenger will come he will show you
things to come so similarly almighty God
he knew very well that when is the right
time for the human beings to receive the
last and final Revelation the Quran and
that was about about 1400 years ago as
far as the second part of the question
is concerned what about the people that
came before the Quran was revealed I
will tell them that if my son goes to
standard one he will not be given the
medical question paper he' be given the
question paper of standard one if he
goes to higher School he'll be given the
question of higher school then Junior
College fine so similarly the basic
message of almighty God in all the
scriptures in all the revelations from
the first revelation till the ration
Quran was the same that you have to
believe in one God that you have to
worship him and no one else to all the
messengers right from the first
messenger Adam peace be upon him write
down to Noah Abraham Moses Jesus
Muhammad peace be upon them all all of
them taught the basic message of Oneness
of God and abouted and about this
message of Oneness of God and toed
inshallah I'll be discussing detail on
the last day of this conference on the
last Sunday that the 20th of January
inshallah hope that answer the
question thank you for the question do
we have another question from a guest
here non-muslim okay we'll go to the
gentleman section rear microphone
gentlemen could you please state your
name and your occupation please good
evening everyone my name is
sanjie um I'm working here in land
Marvel company as an admin
executive uh I got
few questions but I'll ask only two
questions regarding this Islam first
question is uh do Islam believe in
rebirth and second question is in Islam
it's not allowed to commit suicide but
many people that's in Pakistan in Arabic
countries they are uh blowings up and
they are killing many people so who they
who are the peoples they are motivating
them whether they are really following
the Islam or who is motivating them that
is my question sir the brother has two
questions the first question does Islam
believe in rebirth and the second
question that is suicide prohibited in
Islam how come people in Pakistan other
part of the world they're blowing up
themselves and killing themselves the
two questions as far as the first
question is concerned that does Islam
believe in
rebirth if you ask only in rebirth yes
Islam believes in reth rebirth what we
believe that a human beings come to this
world once the Quran says that we give
you life and come on this Earth then we
cause you to die and then we resurrect
you again in the next life this is
exactly what is mentioned in The Vedas
if you read rig book number 10 it speaks
about pun Janam punar means next Janam
means life so the W speaks about pun
Janam about the next life but
unfortunately most of the Hindus they
misunderstand the meaning of pun
Janam punar means next Jam means life we
believe in the next life you say pun jum
you say rebirth we have no problem but
most of the Hindus they believe in a
philosophy known as samsara it's a
Sanskrit word Samara which means birth
death birth death a cycle of
reincarnation a cycle of birth death
birth death birth death this cycle of
birth death birth death or Samara or
reincarnation is nowhere to be found in
The
Vedas what they quote is a verse of
bhagwad
Gita chapter number two verse number 22
which says that like a human being takes
off the old clothes and puts on new
clothes same way the soul throws away
the old body and puts on on the new body
as far as this is concerned I've got no
objection with the bhagat Gita it
further mentioned even in the
upanishads that like a caterpillar walks
up a grass of Blade it jumps onto the
new grass I've got no problem now as far
as the scriptures are concerned if you
take the literal meaning of the W which
does not speak about the cycle of birth
death birth death but only speaks about
Punam next life
Islam speaks the same but most of the
scholars of Hinduism they could not
understand that how can a human being be
born with some congenital
defect how can he be born as a handicap
some are born healthy some are born
handicapped some are born in Rich family
some are born in poor family so they
thought this was
Injustice so how could God be unjust
therefore they propounded the theory of
Samara which is nowhere to be found in
The Vedas The Vedas are considered as
the highest Hindu scriptures in the
Hindu scriptures you have the smti and
you have the shti smiti means scriptures
written by the human beings and shuti
are the vas and nishad considered to be
the word of God now because they could
not justify why some people are born in
Rich family some in poor family some are
unhealthy some with kindal defect they
propounded this theory of samsara as far
as Islam is is concerned Allah says in
the Quran in Surah M chapter number 67
verse number
two it's Allah who has created death and
life to test which of you is good in
Deeds this life you're leading is a test
for the
Hereafter and we believe that every
child is born sinless is born
mum irrespective whether he's born
handicap or healthy whether Rich family
poor family all these things are a test
for the human beings as Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Bak chapter number
two and Surah anal chapter number 8
verse number 28 it says that surely we
will test you with fear and hunger with
loss of
life and loss of what you have earned it
mention Surah chapter number 8 verse
number 28 that your children and your
wives are a test for you now here we
realize that the Quran say the children
are a test for you now if a
child suppose is born
handicapped it's a
test for the parents the parents may be
very good they may be pass maybe Allah
wants to test them more after giving
them a child which is handicapped yet do
they have faith in Allah or not it's a
test so whenever any Calamity befalls
any human being it's either a punishment
or a test whenever any good thing
happens in your life it's either a
reward or it's a
test that does not mean if something bad
happens it has to be a punishment it can
be a punishment it can be a test if
something good happens in your life it
can be a reward or it can be a test so
here almighty God is testing the
parents that do they have faith in
almighty God so if a handicapped child
is born the parent may be an average
Muslim and if he says oh why my child
only has to be born handicapped why my
child has to be born with a congenital
heart disease Allah is testing them
the people who are good Muslims they'll
say Allah destined no problem yet we
thank Allah subhana wa ta'ala and more
difficult the
test more higher is the reward to pass a
simple graduation of ba is easy but to
pass mbbs is difficult the moment you
pass mbbs in front of your name you get
doctor Dr full stop highest status
examination is difficult the honor is
more
so almighty God test different people
different way the child that is born
what the Hindus said the Hindu scholars
in his previous JM in his previous birth
he did the sin therefore he was born
handicapped they didn't have any other
justification if you do good deeds then
you're born healthy so what the Hindu
Scholars they propounded that every
living creature it keeps on changing
according to them the universal
Brotherhood in Hinduism is all living
creatures are your brothers
so sometimes you are born as an animal
sometime as a bird sometime as a rat
sometime as a cockroach sometime as a
human being and the human being is the
highest level and they born as a human
being seven times so they came with this
philosophy because they could not
justify why a child is born rich or poor
handicap or healthy similarly for a
person who's born poor it's a test for
him for the rich people he has to give
zakat every rich person who has a saving
of more than a nisab level 85 grams of
gold he or she should give 2.5% of that
saving every lunar year in charity for
the poor
person for him he gets full marks in
zakat he's poor so he has to give no
zakat 100 out of 100 but we say Poor Man
Poor Man Poor Man he has got 100 out of
100 in zakat the rich man if he gives
proper zakat he make get 100 out of 100
he says okay fine I've got so much
wealth this part is Exempted from zakat
he may give
50% of zakat so he'll get negative
points he may not give zakat at all
imagine suppose there's a questioner
there's a question in a question paper
which is very easy should you be happy
or
sad so when a person is born poor
actually in zakat he gets 100 out of 100
therefore beloved Prophet said it's
easier for a poor man to go to jna than
a rich man but we say poor man how sad
not sad 100 out of 100 in
zakat for the rich man he has to give
charity he has to give zakat he has to
give donation he'll be accountable for
his
wealth so what in Islam we are born in
this world once and once is sufficient
once we die we are resurrected on the
day of judgment you want to call it
rebirth I've got no problem you want to
call Punam I've got no problem we say
life after
death but surely if I agree with you for
sake of argument for sake of argument
what the Hindu Scholars profound that
you
know sometime you're born as animal
sometime bird sometime human being I
want to ask you the question brother in
this
world as every year is passing on is the
population of the human beings
increasing or decreasing
brother increasing or
decreasing increasing increasing very
good is the sin in the world increasing
or
decreasing I can't hear
you increasing or
decreasing increasing sir sorry
increasing increasing human beings are
increasing and even sin is increasing if
I agree with the philosophy of Hindu
Scholars more the sin increases the
population of human beings should
decrease so therefore I believe in going
to the higher scriptures vas when I talk
we had given the talk earlier in ch
during the first piece conference that
was in 2004 similarities between Islam
and Hinduism and there I showed and
compared that even in v it speaks about
one God no idol worship and everything
so what is common between the scriptures
we follow so this the cycle of samsara
birth death birth death is nowhere to be
found in The Vedas it's the philosophy
of the Hindu Scholars to justify because
they could not justify why human beings
are born poor or healthy which I've
given you the answer in
Islam as far as the second question is
concerned that is suicide Haram in Islam
is it prohibited if yes then why do
people commit suicide is somebody
instigating them suicide bombing the
Quran says in Surah Bak chapter number
two verse 195 that do not make your own
hands the cause of your destruction so
according to the Quran committing
suicide is Haram it is
prohibited so as far as committing
suicide is prohibited as far as killing
any other innocent human being the Quran
says in Surah MAA chapter number 5 verse
number 32 that if anyone kills any other
human being whether it be a Muslim or
non-muslim unless it be for murder or
for spreading corruption in the land it
is as though he has killed the whole of
humanity and if anyone saves an human
being it is as though you saved the
whole of humanity so killing any
innocent human being whether it be a
Muslim or non-muslim it is prohib in
Islam so if
anyone whether he puts a bomb without
killing himself or with killing himself
if he kills innocent human being it is
prohibited so as far as killing innocent
human being is concerned it is
prohibited if you use it as a strategy
of
War you know the Japanese used to do the
suicide you know initially where do you
get suicide bumping from According to a
Professor who wrote a book dying to win
in
America he says that the first people
who did suicide bombing were the
LT Tamil Tigers but yet the blame is put
on Muslims I don't know why it's the
media have you ever
heard of any Muslim doing suicide
bombing it was first the
LT and then the Americans and maybe some
of the Muslims black sh may have picked
up but who were The
Originators but yet when suicide bombing
comes the terrorists are labeled the
Muslims in chai a few years back i' also
given a talk on terrorism and Jihad an
Islamic perspective but I've described
in detail about this answer of suicide
bombing as far as Islamic perspective is
concerned but killing innocent human
being and committing suicide is Haram
hope the answer the question
M thank you for the question we'll go to
the the front mic with the MS if there
are any other non-muslims at the back
mic or the sister's mics just have the
volunteers raise their hands any
non-muslim ladies they most welcome to
ask the question and if there any
non-muslim in the audience please feel
free to come up on the microphone it's
your opportunity and as previous times
I've come to Chin alhamdulillah all the
questions asked by non-muslims so I hope
even now the non-muslims of chin M the
bold enough you can ask any question
even if it's a criticism even if you
disagree whatever I say no problem come
up and ask the question believe me I'm
young but I can take it you can
criticize the Quran you can criticize
Islam you can ask this is the
opportunity please come up on the
microphone and have the doubt cleared
this is the opportunity and there you've
heard it from the man himself
so your name and occupation please my
name is ramakrishan I'm a software
engineer I have two questions for you
the first is what does Islam say about
organs after death is it okay or is it
prohibited second question is what does
Islam say about
atheists that's it the brother has two
questions I think non-muslim are one
asking two no problem the first question
is what does Islam say about donating
organs second question is about atheist
as far as the first question is
concerned what does Islam say about
donating organs there's no direct verse
in the Quran or any say Hadith which
which says whether organs can be donated
or not but there are various conferences
that have held in Saudi Arabia in
Malaysia and various different parts of
the world and the scholars have come to
Common consensus that if three things
are fulfilled then organs can be donated
number one the person who requires an
organ but natural it should be a major
benefit to his health he can receive
organ as long as it's a the benefit or
saves his life Point number two the
person donating the organ after he
donates the organ it should not be a
major loss to his health for example if
I donate my heart I will die so I can't
donate my heart but the doctors say that
out of two kidneys present a person can
even survive with one kidney so if my
mother has a kidney failure both the
kidneys have failed I can very well
donate my one kidney to my mother even
she lives when I
live but naturally after a person dies
if he wants to donate any other organ
that is permissible but if he's alive he
should not donate any part of the body
which will cause a major damage to his
health or a loss of life and the third
criteria is it should not be for money
no one should sell organ if all these
three conditions are fulfilled then
organ donation very well can be done as
far as the second question is concerned
what does Islam have to say about
atheist as far as I'm
concerned whenever I meet an
atheist are you an atheist brother he
said no
whenever I meet an atheist the first
thing I do is I congratulate that
atheist people may wonder that why is
Zak congratulate atheist the reason I'm
congratulate atheist is because most of
the human beings they usually do blind
belief he is a Hindu because father is
Hindu he is a Christian father is a
Christian many Muslims are Muslims
because father is a Muslim now this
atheist he's thinking he may be coming
from a religious background his father
may be
Pious but he does not
believe that how can there be a God who
requires to eat a God who can die a God
who can lie so the reason I congrat The
Atheist is because he has said the first
part of the Islamic shahada Islamic
creeda that there is no God the only
thing I have to do is ill but Allah
which I shall do inshallah so half my
job is done to a non
Muslim who believes in some other God
first have to prove to him that the God
is worshiping is
wrong and after I prove to him that the
God is worshiping is wrong then I have
to prove to him about the correct God
here The Atheist half my job is done he
already agrees in the first part of the
Islamic shahada there is no God the only
thing I have to do is which I shall do
inshallah the first question asked to
The Atheist is
that what is the definition of
God if anyone says there's no God to say
there is no God he should know the
definition of God if he does not know
the definition of God he cannot say
there's no God for
example if I say this is a
pen is this a pen no it's a book to say
this is not a pen you should know the
definition of
pen some people say no I know this is a
book so I can say it's not a pen I said
no if you know the definition of pen I
will say is this a kitab you say no it
is not a kab because there no definition
of kab to say it's not a kab you should
know the definition of
kitab because kitab and book is the same
so to say it is not a pen you have to
know the definition of pen you may or
may not know the definition of a book
correct
similarly to say there is no God you
should know the definition of God so now
this person who the atheist he's
believing oh that God he requires to eat
he can lie he fights and he loses he
does not believe in a God so I say when
I don't believe in such a
God then I tell to him the correct
concept of God and the correct concept
of God is mentioned surlas chapter
number 112 verse number 1 to 4 which I
discussed in the last last day of the
conference inshallah that is on 20th of
January so what he's doing he is
rejecting the false
card then I asked the question to The
Atheist that if Suppose there is
equipment which is bought in front of
you who no one in the world has ever
seen no one knows about it and if I ask
the question that who will be the first
person who will be able to tell you the
mechanism of their
equipment The Atheist will tell the
first person who will tell the mechanism
of this equipment who know what in the
world is seen it is the
creator some may say the manufacturer
some may say the inventor some will say
the person who has made it maker he may
say Creator maker inventor manufacturer
whatever he says it will be somewhat
similar don't grapple with the words
what he says accepted then ask him then
repeat the lecture which I gave which I
don't intern reading
that how did the universe come into
existence so he will tell about the Big
Bang then I'll tell him that when did
you come to know he will tell you in
1973 yesterday in science 30 years back
40 years back I will say what you are
talking about the big bang you came to
know 30 years back is mentioned in the
Quran 1400 years ago who could have
mentioned it he say maybe it's a FL
don't argue with him continue what's the
shape of the earth he will tell you
previously people thought it's flat now
we know it's fill when when did you come
to know he will tell you 1577 when s
Francis Drake sailed around the
earth men 300 years back 400 years back
450 years back the Quran mentions 1400
years ago who could have mentioned it
you would say oh maybe your Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him he was
intelligent man don't argue continue
light of the moon is its own light or
reflected light he will tell you
previously we thought light of the moon
was its own light recently we have come
to know a couple of hundred years back
it's reflected light it's mentioned in
the Quran Surah fan 25:
light of the mo is reflected 14 years
back who could have mentioned it now
we'll pause don't wait for the answer
continue in school I was taught that the
sun was stationary it did not rotate
about his AES you is that mention the
Quran I said no that's what I learned in
school but the Quran says the Sun and
the Moon rotate which we have come to
recently in school 25 years back I was
told the sun did not rotate the Quran
says 400 years back that the sun rotates
with science I discovered today who
could have mentioned that there'll be a
pause don't wait for the reply continue
so all the scientific things I mentioned
in my talk after each scientific fact
ask him who could have mentioned it
before and finally he will tell the
Creator the manufacturer the inventor
the maker this Creator this manufacturer
this producer this inventor we in Islam
call is
Allah that's the reason today science is
not eliminating
Goda it is eliminating models of God
illah therefore so Francis Bacon a very
famous philosopher he said that little
knowledge of science makes you an
atheist in-depth knowledge of science
makes you a believer in
God so with this help of this lecture
Quran modern science you can prove the
existence of God scientifically hope
that answer the question
go ahead and state your question I
remind the sisters inshallah to motivate
those non-muslim sisters that may be
amongst you to ask their questions this
is an excellent opportunity for them so
you should really try to motivate them
to come to the microphones brother my
name is rates and I'm a student studying
11th standard my question is uh all the
religions have limitations of clothing
uh let me be specific to the women uh
but they've changed with time
but why is the bka still the same why
hasn't that changed with time and uh one
more question uh I'm sorry uh during
Raman I've seen all the Muslims will be
fasting the brother said that by the
passage of time every religion has got
clothing for women but by the passage of
time the clothing keeps on changing but
why the Muslim women yet wear the bka as
far as the clothing is is concerned
brother in Islam there are six criteria
for clothing for the man it from the nil
to the knee that is the extent it should
be covered for the woman the complete
body should be covered the only part
that can be seen are the face and hands
up to the rest there are certain
Scholars who say that even this should
be covered the remaining five criteria
are the same for the man and the woman
the second is the clothes where it
should not be so tight so that it Rees
the figure it should be loose the third
is it should not be translucent or
transparent so that you can see through
the fourth is it should not be So
Glamorous so that it attracts the
opposite sex fifth it should not
resemble that of the unbeliever and six
it should not resemble that of the
opposite sex these are basically the six
criteria and most of these six criteria
are even mentioned in the other
scriptures if you read the Bible it's
mentioned in the Bible in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 22 verse
number five it says that the woman shall
not wear clothes that which perate to a
man man and a man shall not wear clothes
that which perate to woman all those who
do this they are creating an Abomination
it further mention in the Bible in the 1
Timothy chapter number two verse number
9 that the women should be dressed up
with shamefacedness and sobriety they
should not wear costly aray pearls and
gold and further mentioned in the First
Corinthians chapter number 11 verse
number
5-6 that the woman that that PRI with
the head
uncovered her head should be shaved off
there's no verse in the Quran and the
Hadith which says that the woman who
does not cover a head should be shaved
off but the Bible is
stricter Bible is stricter than the
Quran that if the woman that praise does
not cover the that that should be shaved
off the same thing in the Hindu
scripture if you read the Hindu
scriptures it's mentioned ramayan that
when pasuram when he comes to Ram he
says to his wife SAA that he the Elder
therefore lower your gaze and guard your
modesty it further mentioned if you read
r book number 10 chapter number5 verse
number 30 it says that the woman who
wears the clothes of that of a man she's
defiling it she should not bear the
clothes of a man further it's mentioned
that in rig book number eight that
Brahma has ordered that the woman should
cover ahead so in Hindu scriptures
Christian scriptures Muslim
scriptures modesty is there covering the
head is there by the passage of time I
do agree with you that Christianity
now you only see the nuns covering the
head they are called Pious if Muslim
women cover their hair they are called a
subjugated why double standards if you
see a none covered properly if you see
the photograph of mother Mary have you
seen the photograph of Mother Mary like
a muslima and she was a muslima Muslim
woman properly covered with the wrist
only face Fe what I do agree with you if
you stick to the six criteria by
fashion the types of hijab the bka Abaya
has changed as long as you follow the
six principles of Islam and you change
the color from black to Blue to Brown no
problem as long as you don't break any
of the six criteria
therefore you see new new styles of
hijab but some styles of bka they are so
fashionable that they break the law of
Islam there are so many shiny sequences
coming that you're attracting the
opposite sex so that is Haram but
otherwise you want to wear red you want
to wear black color no problem people
think black is compulsory black is not
compulsory if you wear black maybe you
may have to wash the borka once in a
week if you wear white you may have to
wash every day the choice is yours you
you wear white and wash it every day you
wear black and wash it once a week
choice is yours as long as it doesn't
break any of the criteria six criterias
of hijab so now there are new types of
hijab coming as long as it doesn't break
you're allowed but it should be modest
if it's modest it's
accepted second question that you see in
Ramadan that people fast when they fast
in the day in the evening they
feast and i' would like to thank you
asking this question see why do we fast
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse 183 that
fasting has been prescribed to you as it
was prescribed to people who came before
you so that you may learn self-restraint
you may learn
TAA and today scientists they tell us if
you can control your hunger you can
control almost all your
desires so if you can fast you can
control your other desires but I do
agree with you if not all many Muslims
if you say most also I would not mind
agreeing with you that they fast and
when they break the fast they Feast so
that defeats the purpose I do agree with
you and many of them convert the day
into night and night into
day they sleep the full day and the full
night they're playing Cricket in India
cricket so you have to lead a normal
life like a normal life you have to do
more I you have to worship God more so
normally when you fast but natural your
meals are reduced it is medically
beneficial but if you
ovat then there'll be a problem but if
you do it the correct way there are
various medical benefits of fasting
which you can refer to my video cassette
and I've given 64 episodes on fasting
which come during Ramadan and inshallah
you can watch the various benefits of
fasting hope that answer the
question sister side if you have a
question from a non-muslim sister could
you please State itam alaykum this is on
behalf of a non-muslim sister wandana
she says I'm new to this concept have
limited knowledge therefore asking a
basic question if out of 6,000 verses
thousand are about scientific facts then
what really is the essence of the
Quran the sister as a very good question
that if the Quran contains more than
6,000
verses and more than a thousand speak
about SS what is the of the Quran sister
as I mentioned my earlier answer the
basic essence of the Quran
is believing in one God and worshiping
him alone and no one else and the Quran
as I mentioned not a book of science SC
i e n c it's a book of signs s i g NS
it's a book of ayats the
Quran is a book which shows you how a
life should be
led and when I had a debate with Shish
raish Shankar I said this is the best
book on Art of
Living if there's any book on Art of
Living which is the best it is the
Quran best book on Art of Living and it
has a membership of more than 1.3
billion people so this book shows you
how to lead a life now many times you
understand that because the Quran is the
word of almighty God one verse of the
Quran has got multiple angles now the
same thousand verses which are speaking
about science it doesn't mean it only
speaks about science it speaks about
various other aspects also that's the
beauty of the
Quran when a lame man sees it he
understands it when a scientific man
sees it he sees it a different angle it
satisfies both so that's the beauty of
the Quran that does not mean that Quran
is a book of science yes but there is
not a single verse of the Quran which
goes against established
science because it's book of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala almighty God so this
book is a book of guidance how a life
should be led it shows a person to
believe in Oneness of God how to worship
Him and how to lead the life the pros
and cons the far what a human being
should do and the prohibited things that
he should abstain from it's mentioned in
the Quran hope that ansers the question
sister sister if you have another
question go ahead if it's from a
non-muslim your presentation is an
impressive but could you just ask this
group to raise their hands who knew some
of the information that you mention now
the thought here is why is general
education and the learning of the Holy
Quran not
interated sister has a question that
from the audience how many of you knew
the major portion of what I've said in
the lecture please raise your
hand major portion of what I've
mentioned m you can say most of them at
least more than 50% if not
all and the reason is that I written a
book also Quran and modern science
compatible and compatible which has been
distributed in the
conference if those who have not got a
copy inshallah on your way out the copy
of my talk Quran and modern science will
be distributed inshallah it's a
four-color book regarding the part of
the question the second part that why
isn't
education being given to the Muslims so
I expected the sister would have thought
that maybe 1% or 10% less than 10%
raised the hand so here you see
mashallah majority knew it and yet they
came for the talk alhamdulillah maybe
they came for the question answer
session that's the best part of the
program sister as far as Islam is
concerned the first guidance given by
almighty God in the Glorious Quran in
the last and final revelation of the
human beings it was not to offer Salah
it was not to perform Haj or pilgrimage
it was read recite Proclaim so the first
guidance given by almighty God in the
last and final Revelation it was to read
it was education and that the reason the
major stress that the Muslim should put
is on education and alhamdulillah the
people of the South I know from Kerala
and even of Madras mashallah of
chenai as far as the percentage is
concerned in the other parts of India
alhamdulillah the Muslims in Kerala are
100% educated not Muslims all carolites
whether Muslim or non-muslim they
educated so even culture counts into it
as far as the religion of Islam is
concerned every Muslim he should be
educated so that's a message for those
who are not educated that acquiring
education is important and that is the
first guidance given by Allah subhana
tala in the last and final revelation
the Glorious Quran hope that the
question if the sister could please stay
at the microphone I'll come back to you
after I take a question from the
gentleman side if you have more
questions from non-muslims if there's
another sister who has a question
non-muslim then please allow her to come
to the mic and ask her question as well
but until then I'll go with the brother
in the front good evening again everyone
uh it was amazing to see how much signs
that the Glorious Quran contained after
your talk but in most of the examples
from the Quran which you gave it is very
difficult to comprehend what the Quran
tells before actually the science
discovers or invents that particular
phenomenon for example you said in the
honey there is healing of humanity in
the Quran and you mention it as it's
about if a person is maybe say poison
with a plant the honey of the plant
should be taken so what is the use say
of a Almighty Holy Scripture talking
about things which are only able to
comprehend after the real invention is
made by science so can you tell me now
something from the Quran which will be
invented by science later or yet to be
invented brother a good question that
I've mentioned many things about science
indirectly saying all this already
discovered earlier and if Quran says
something and after science has
discovered so what's the use can you
tell me something which science hasn't
discovered brother that's the reason the
Arabs who advanced in the field of
astronomy why because they read the
Quran the Quran has a lot of information
on astronomy so when they read the Quran
they try and do more investigation they
do more research and that's how they
come to know Quran is a telegraphic
message this is the book of science only
on one
subject in medicine one subject only
requires volumes so if that way the
Quran is this Quran most of the human
beings they don't like to read oh such a
big book so if God Almighty wrote In
detail then even a big building
you'll require thousands of buildings to
contain the message of the Quran Quran
is telegraphic message so in telegraphic
message many of the Muslims they read
the Quran and they made advances in
science that's the reason we find if you
go back into
history the Muslims advanced in science
and technology but you pose the question
forget about the past what about today
all what I've mentioned has been
discovered earlier but many of them were
discovered by Muslims some by
non-muslims some by your Europeans what
about things which science hasn't
discovered fine first I'll tell you
those things which science hasn't
established but yet there are high
chances which Quran has testified and I
believe in it for example Quran says in
Sur chapter number 42 verse number 29
that it's Allah subhana wa ta'ala who
has created the creatures in the heavens
and the Earth and has placed creatures
in them so Quran says there is life
besides this Earth today s hasn't proved
there is life besides this earth
scientists say there are high
possibilities that life will be there
besides this Earth so they're sending
Rockets spaceships Moon Mars Quran says
there life beside this Earth I believe
in it science may discover it tomorrow
after 5 years after 10 years after 100
years Quran says I believe in
it today there are many
hypothesis how the world will
end it says that the sun will become big
and the world will end the mountains
will fall down the mountains will become
smooth the ocean will swell up the world
will enter into black hole many
hypothesis many of these hypothesis not
all they match with the
Quran Quran says in Surah chapter number
75 verse number 8 and 9 that the Sun and
the Moon they will join together the sun
will be buried in darkness if you read
Sur chapter number 81 verse 1 2 and
three it says that the Stars will fall
down and lose their luster the mountain
will fall down toter ruin the ocean will
swell up it's mentioned in Surah infar
chapter number 82 verse 1 and 2 and 3
again the ocean will fell up the Stars
will fall down similar to many of the
hypothesis but Quran says I believe in
it Quran further says in Sur Amia
chapter number 21 verse number 104 we
have created this creation we will
destroy it and create a new
creation science hasn't discovered that
yet Quran speaks about life after death
science hasn't proved that yet Quran
speaks about heaven and hell science
hasn't proved about that Quran speaks
about Jin today psychologist say extr
terrest power there are some people who
get possessed with
jins Quran speaks about that Quran
speaks the first man on the earth while
Adam peace be upon Him science has
improved there high possibility science
will prove now you may ask me that
brother Zakir you give such a good talk
on Science and Technology but 100% solid
proof you believe in life after death
you believe in Jin you believe in heaven
and hell you a doctor isn't this
unscientific I said no
brother I
believe that it is scientific suppose
whatever the Quran has mentioned 80% has
proved to be 100% correct I spoke about
astronomy about geology ology motorcycle
oceanography botony biology zoology so
just hypothetically 80% what the Quran
has mentioned suppose has been proved to
be 100% correct the remaining 20% is
ambiguous neither right neither wrong
not even. 1% of that 20% Which is
ambiguous has been proved to be wrong
there is not a single verse of the Quran
which can be proved false by established
science
hypothesis so my logic says when 80% is
100% correct and the remaining 20% is
ambiguous but not even 0.1% of that 20%
is proved wrong so my logic says that
even that 20% inshallah will be correct
if not today tomorrow after 50 years
after 100 years after Thousand Years
Allah Alam God knows they will prove
their life after death they will prove
there is Jin they will prove there is
Hell there is proof there is heaven and
so on and so for for I can give another
lecture on things which science hasn't
proved but inshallah will prove hope
that answers the
question thank you for the question
sister side if you have another question
from a non-muslim sister could you
please state it uh this is the last
question from Sister wandana your memory
and grasping is phenomenal is there any
mention about better memory
power this the question that my memory
is phenomenal through the grace of Allah
tala is there any verse in the Quran
which speaks about memory as far as
people keep on asking me that what is
the secret do you have a comput chip
what is the
secret the
secret it is given in the
Quran and in my dawa training program
which I take for my students I say there
are three things required number
one the Quran says in Surah Al Imran
chapter number three verse number
160 that if Allah helps you none can
overcome you if Allah forsakes you who
is there then who can help you so let
the Believers put the tou in Allah
number one is trust in
Allah number two the Quran says in Surah
anab chapter number 29 verse number 69
if you strive in the way of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala if you struggle and do
Jihad in the way of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala Allah will open up your Pathways
number two is hard
work and number three is Allah says inia
chapter number 21 verse number 7 and
chapter number 16:
43 if you don't know ask the person
who's knowledgeable the third is the
technique the technique which we train
in a dawa training program people ask me
brother Zak what is the technique I
that's the third and the least important
number one is Faith in Allah with all
your techniques in the world you know
many of my students have done MBA and
memorizing technique triangle and horse
I don't know whether you know about the
triangle technique and this and that and
pegging initially they are good students
towards the end they come at the
bottom Allah's help is the best better
than any pegging or any triangle
anything number one how do you get help
if you strive in his way you strive in
his way you have to get success if you
don't get success you are not striving
correctly in the way of Allah subhana
tala regarding technique of memory Etc
that is least
important we have a training course
where we have a 40 days training course
where we train people and mallah you'll
be shocked that even my students
alhamdulillah they quot chapter number
verse number chapter number verse number
we have dawa training program where we
get students from different parts of the
world and we train them and how to give
lectures how to handle question answer
session it's training and hard work also
as far as the ver of the Quran is
concerned before the beginning of my
talk I always quote a verse of the
Quran from Surah T chapter number 20
verse number 25 and 28 which
says this was a Dua when almighty God
Allah subhana wa taala tells to Moses
that go and deliver the
message and before delivering the
message
Moses who was a stutterer he used to
stammer and those who know me personally
even I was a
stammerer when I was a child and in my
dream a person can dream of anything in
the
world in my dream I could have dreamed
of becoming the best surgeon in the
world but I couldn't have dreamed of
speaking in front of 25 people because I
was a stammerer people ask me what is
your name my name is
was me now coming in the way of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
maybe about 10 15 years back when I get
war in the field of dawa when I started
doing daad staming wasn't there when I
spoke with Christian Missionary staming
used to vanish I never thought of
becoming a
speaker I came on the stage because my
colleague was cold feet I came it
clicked and now I'm on the stage and now
by Allah's Grace I give lectures to tens
of thousands of people hundreds of
thousands of people the largest
gathering is a million people live
alhamdulillah
that comes back to the verse of the
Quran when Moses was asked by Allah
subhana wa taala to deliver the message
to Fon and his people he read a Dua a
Dua a prayer from Surah T chapter number
20 verse number 25-28 which
says oh my Lord expand my breath for me
expand my center for
me and make my task easy for me
[Music]
and remove the impediment from my speech
because mus Alam was a stammerer I also
was a stammerer remove the impediment
from a speech so that they will
understand me so the people to whom I'm
delivering the message I ask Allah
subhana wa ta'ala to expand my breath
for me to make my task easy for me
remove the impediment from my speech so
that the people understand me so this is
a Dua which can also be used for memory
but the main is having faith in Allah
second is striving hard and third is
technique hope to answer the
question that will be the last question
for the evening and with that we would
like to end this the second night of the
10day International Conference and
exhibition brought to you by peace
vision of Islam for harmony awareness
and
education for your attendance
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh